everybody welcome to live coding with
Jesse I'm Jesse today we're going to do
something new that we've never done on
this dream and something that I have
never done we are going to start
building an electron app so if you're
not familiar with electron I'll take a
minute here and explain to the best of
my ability what electron is so electron
was developed by github specifically to
build atom their editor but now it's
been used for a lot of other things so
if you ever use the slack desktop app or
a Visual Studio code and there's a lot
of other things get crack in so it's
it's a way to use HTML CSS and
JavaScript to build applications that
run on the desktop so they run like
native applications native desktop
applications and a lot of most people
can't tell the difference so we're going
to use that we're going to take in the
project that we've already done and
react which is the Resource Center and
we're going to make a desktop app
version of it so we're still going to
use react we'll probably just create
react app and then but we're also going
to use electron with it
so since I've never setup a project like
this before I'm not sure how long it'll
take
we're gonna try to get as much stuff as
we can today I do have a meeting at 3:00
so that's so it's 1:30 my time so in
less than an hour and a half is it's a
little after 1:30 I'll have to be at a
meeting so I'm thinking maybe two
Pomodoro sessions and then questions
after so that's the that's the plan
today let me show you
what I'm using so let me switch up here
you can see what I see alright so this
is the article that I found that I'm
gonna use now if anybody has used
electron before specifically electron
with react let me know if there's some
better way to do this that you know of
otherwise I mean I've spent a really
long amount of time but I spent a little
while checking out different articles
and different github repos on ways to
start up your project with react and
electron so this is what I found this
article from react to an electron app
ready for production and it has this
awesome picture check that out I want
that as a sticker on a laptop that would
be sweet is there some company where I
can just send the picture into and
they'll print me out a laptop sticker
they've got to be something like that
out there but that's a cool one anyway I
don't know who drew this I don't want to
just steal it off the ask permission I
guess see who made that anyway enough of
this thicker stuff so I'm gonna pull
this off the screen and then so I'll
have more room to work with
at first we'll just be working in the in
the terminal here and then we'll switch
over to our code editor at some point
assuming we get far enough to to do that
so these instructions came out June 13th
of this year so they're not really
really up to date but I think they
should this should work I was looking
through it they are you know they're
using it seems like pretty up-to-date
stuff I know you know we've had a major
react you know update with version 16
but we're gonna give it a shot and as
long as it's still early on in the
project if we find out like today or you
know maybe the next day or something
that hey there's some better way to do
it then we haven't lost very much time
we'll just wish to
okay I'm sure if you've watched before
you've all seen me totally switch up a
project even a week or two weeks in
alright awesome so we got decent number
of viewers hey everybody especially if
if you haven't joined before I'm about
to start doing some coding and during
that time I'm not really gonna look at
the live chat much so if you asked a
question just hang on for a little bit
after a 25-minute period is up which I'm
going to start a timer right now for
that
so after this 25-minute period is up
I'll go back to the live chat read
through as much as I can answer as many
questions as I can and then I'm gonna do
another 25 minute session of coding and
then at the end of that I'll answer all
your questions unless I get a lot of
questions because I do have to go to my
meeting but usually I can answer all the
questions so let's get started let me
make this a bit bigger I want to make
sure everybody can see also we did get
some pull requests so we got a lot of
pull requests that I merged maybe if we
have time later on I'll go through what
happened because there were several
projects that you get pull requests so
I'll catch I'll try to catch you all up
on on what went on if I don't have time
today then we'll just catch up tomorrow
all right so first things first let's go
to our my projects folder so I'm going
to CD projects alright now we're just
gonna do a simple will create react app
right we've done this before so let's
use create react add
and let's do which we call this let's
stick with let's go with our C electron
so the resource center electron so we
know what we're using and let's see yeah
that's it so we should need so this when
I hit enter it should create a folder
for us called our C electron and then
within that folder it's going to give us
everything we need to have a react app
and in fact it will be a working react
app but we can't stop there because we
wanted to also work on a desktop with
electron so as soon as this is finished
we're also going to add electron okay so
you can see when you fit if you haven't
used this before it's kind of nice when
it finishes it tells you exactly what
was created and where it's at tells you
commands to get started you'll be using
start the most out of any of these you
may never use eject and then even get
less you tells you right away just type
these two things and you'll be good so
first thing we're gonna do is what it
says your new RC electron so now we're
in that folder if I show all the files
you can see we already have a readme
package.json got a node module so we
have everything like I said everything
we need for react so now let's do the
electron port
I'm gonna copy and paste because it's a
lot and I don't want to mess it up
so I'm a copy and paste and then we'll
go through so we're gonna do a yarn ad
right so if you use NPM you can do NPM
install and it'll do the same thing so
we're installing we're adding the NPM
packages for electron we're going to use
the electron builder which this will
help us whenever we actually want to
make this an app that can run natively
we're gonna get weighed on and
currently and then we're saving these as
dev dependencies so you'll see what
we're getting these for in a minute
that's gonna help with like our scripts
let's see so let's hit enter I'll have a
lot to install hopefully it doesn't take
too long
all right well that's going I'll check
the lab chat whoops
it already worked awesome so I don't
think we got any errors awesome now we
need to add one more thing
yarn add electron is dev I honestly have
no idea what this thing does but it says
to download it in the tutorial and I did
not even see it mentioned when I read
through the tutorial which I admit I
didn't read every word of this so I
expect that I'm gonna mess up at some
point during this at least once so just
fair warning everybody but that's kind
of what this stream is all about I mean
we do want to make cool stuff and then
hopefully we all learn something but I
mean really like the street is so y'all
can see me mess up right and then try to
get out of it together okay awesome we
have everything cool we need to add an
electron dot JS file so that electron
works with create react app so you'll be
able to see what this file is in a
minute let's let's tell you what let's
do this I talked to I know a lot of you
have been recommending Visual Studio
code and I talked to some people at that
November at the conference and they were
saying you know some of them had
switched from Adam to Visual Studio code
and they're saying how much they liked
it so I went ahead and I I downloaded
some react plug-ins for Visual Studio
code and I haven't tested them out yet
but I think it would be cool to try to
do this project in Visual Studio code
let me pull it over here first so let's
go with its openness project
I folded a workspace and we had projects
and then here's our C electron project
let's add it awesome good stuff so let's
go into our public folder and we want to
add let's make this big there we go and
then I can increase the fontsize rates
all right so now hopefully y'all can see
and I'm gonna add a new file and we're
gonna call this file electron j/s and
then I'm gonna paste this in so let's
check this out I haven't even looked at
this file yet let's look at it a bit and
see what what's going on here so one of
the plugins that I downloaded comes with
this this stuff so it tells me how big
all of these things I'm importing are
which i think is really cool probably
won't really make a difference unless
you know we import something and it's
like huge and then maybe we might think
about trying to use something else but I
thought it's pretty cool actually use
the thing called it was a called
food truck react food truck so you just
pull you get the plug-in called react
food truck and then it installs a bunch
of other react plugins I'm not gonna go
through them all now but they all seem
super helpful so that's where I got most
of these plugins that I'm using so if
anyone's interested in that you want
more info I can I guess I'll just send a
link right now
let me put the link in the live chat
right now so y'all can check that out if
you want there we go so it's in there
now
alright so let's let's go through this
and make this there we go let me know if
you can't see if the font is too small
so oh I just glanced the live chat and
it is harsh it's birthday happy birthday
so hard should you're 16 now right let
me know if I'm wrong but oh no the links
are 404 page no let me why is it a 404
page let me get rid of all that junk at
the end of the link and see if it still
works no it doesn't all right here I'm
just gonna paste the title in here if
you try to google that title then I'm
hoping it'll come up I don't know what's
going on with the link it works it works
on my machine right I hate saying that
but in this case it's true alright so so
we're bringing in electron obviously
electron dot AB browser window also so
if you don't know I guess electron does
what it does because it's built on top
of chromium which is like I guess like
the core code of chrome the Chrome
browser something like that I'm not
really an expert on know how that works
but you can make JavaScript CSS HTML app
and then it runs on chromium but it runs
in such a way that it looks
and behaves like a native app like you
you can have access to like the file
structure and things like that
I believe okay so like I said not the
expert first time I'm working with it
but I'm that's at least kind of big
picture how it works so not only you
know do you get the app but you also get
chromium bundled with it which is
basically the reason why I want to do
this because then we I do not have to
deal with outdated browsers and issues
with that because we've had a really big
problem with computers on campus here at
the university I worked for having very
outdated versions of browsers like I'm
talking about browsers that came out in
2007 right so we don't have to worry
about this at all and I I came up with
this idea at November talking with
someone who actually works on the
electron project they worked for github
Sharon I can't remember her last name
but anyway she was one of the speakers
at November so if you check out the
November site and the speakers I'm
pretty sure she's the only speaker named
Sharon and she's from github so anyway
so based on what she was saying about
electron it just occurred to me wait
that could solve a lot of our problems
so anyway that's why I thought we should
do it and it'd be cool to learn how to
do this okay so anyway okay cool so it
looks like this is just kind of setting
up electron and setting up everything to
run so great let's move on
all right so let's go to our
package.json and we need to configure
that to actually know where this file is
right and use it so yeah package.json
great all right so we're gonna add
actually I shouldn't I think there's a
completed repo of this there we go there
is an example repo which is going to be
super helpful you know how and when
you're using a tutorial they just give
you tiny snippets and it's not always
that obvious where the snippets are
supposed to go so I am going to also
have the repo open at the same time so
that I could see like the final picture
and what's going on with that okay cool
so let's put in main oops
main and then public
public electron Jaso that just tells it
where that file is yeah and
so now we're going to add a script oops
sorry
I scrolled down too far I'm not there
yet we're still getting ahead of script
though I'm gonna copy and paste this
because this is long and complicated so
let's see in our scripts here we are in
our scripts I'm gonna add this after
eject you could put it anywhere but I'm
gonna add it there and you see we have
this big string and then you should be
able to run after we do this so let me
save this and let's run it let's run
this script and see what happens we're
not finished setting it up yet but this
is good for dev at least it should be
alright so what we just call that script
electron dev alright so yarn electron
dev
all right now the air is so far
something's already running on for 3,000
know what I've run
I've way too many terminal tabs open all
right all right let me turn this up okay
I got it I got it it was our it was our
next app that we're building for that
main site all right so let's let's try
now there we go
yeah cool and it runs it on the network
- very cool let me do this and then also
let me run it on on and rock and see see
what that's like
all right check it out we have a react
app running on localhost let me put this
I got my anger out going on another
window here let me paste in the URL
alright so if anybody wants to check it
out there's the link in the live chat
and grukk lets you all inspect this and
let's see yeah way to the window and I
have it running in the browser but it's
not running it's not running like you a
normal electron app would run so I'm
trying to check out my windows here and
see where it popped up
where are you
so I have an electron icon here you may
not be able to see it it's probably
underneath all right so you might you
can barely see it right there in the
bottom right hand corner
well wise they're not showing me
anything all right let's move around a
bit and see you know yeah
let's move that over here while we're
while we're here let's move this over
okay hmm let me before I keep searching
let's just read this output and see if
it says anything
all right so I don't see anything in the
mhm so I I don't see anything in the
tutorial that we're following that we
did wrong I'm gonna scroll back up yeah
it looks like everything was fine so I
guess we could just try it again let's
do that
strut again and let me make sure I'm not
running anything else I don't think I am
okay and I'm gonna exit this out too I
highly doubt that's affecting it but
that was our our app we are react native
app I have running on Expo alright so
let's get out of this
let's chat again nicely area
let me check the live chat just to see
if anybody has any ideas
I see Michaels idea have you tried
turning it off and back on again that's
a good idea
all right so
why is it showing sound coming from my
react native debugger that's weird let's
get out of it okay actually I didn't
check on this screen let me check on
this screen just in case no nothing hmm
all right let me I'm gonna quit the
electron that was open in the bottom and
then try this again see if it makes a
difference I knew something would go
wrong when we're setting this up let me
check the lab chat again take my time
alright so in about two minutes I'm
gonna go over the live chat and try to
read through all your comments and
questions
hmm okay that's interesting so I am
getting the electron coming back up and
electrons coming back up in my taskbar
or whatever it's called at the bottom of
the Mac window
hmm
really uh okay it looks like
alright here's the link okay so hard
[ __ ] has a link to the Quick Start Guide
let's check this out
no I'm again a fluorophore
all right so let me let's do the break
okay and let me go to the live chat so
if you asking questions I'm gonna try to
get to him right now I'm gonna scroll up
a bit and oh cool I was asking about
making this sticker and Brian said
sticker mule alright I have to check
that out thank you okay
Michael was asking about like what's
going on with this project what project
is it so yeah it's we're just going to
take the resource center that we've
already built and react and we're going
to make it an electron version of it so
we're still going to have that Resource
Center site available for the browser
but we're also going to have a mobile
app and we're going to have a desktop
app
oh okay so urine said I tried to give
you a link earlier to a visual studio
code package and it didn't work but
urine said that if you google it and
then click the link it's the same link
but it doesn't give the 404 error so I
know isn't that that's weird like it
works anyway uh-huh so I guess it will
work if you google it
how should I so how check polyfill I Oh
I did check that out hard [ __ ] I just
didn't have time to actually get it to
put it on that project and test it out
so I will get to that at some point hmm
sorry
brian says still using Netscape
Navigator is there a better browser yeah
I mean what why did we ever need
anything else besides Netscape Navigator
Sean P says you should update ie6 it's
the best michael says you're gonna use
Visual Studio instead of Adam for a
project based on chromium interesting
actually Visual Studio code is also
based on on chromium so they're both
electron apps which is interesting
because I've heard people complain about
adam and adam is so slow in electron is
so slow but then you have Visual Studio
code that people say so fast and it also
runs on electron right so I don't think
the problem is electron it's probably
just how you use electron right and
since adam was like one of the I think
the first electron app maybe there's
some legacy stuff for optimizations that
just still there Visual Studio codes a
lot newer I don't know I don't really
know but that'd be my guest to explain
the difference brian says youngbae do
you have a set of floppies for ie6 you
can send me let's see
that's all right Steve Stevie came in it
says Wyatt why electron I want to use
electron the idea is basically if I use
electron then the people who download
this app I don't have to worry about
their versions of their browser right
cuz they're gonna have chromium
installed with this so I'll just get
around all the problems that I've been
having with people using really really
old browsers gander 7s which tutorial
are you following I'm gonna throw this
up on the screen now I'm using this
tutorial from react to an electron app
ready for production I guess I can paste
this in as well if you all want to see
it and Stephen also just for some
context on the video is this the first
time you are using electron yes
definitely the first time Michael says
I'm confused what is is not happening
okay so base let me let me scroll down
and show you what's supposed to happen
is I'm supposed to get a window like
this so it's supposed to look like a
native app in not a browser window so I
can open this in a browser window which
is awesome but it's not really any
different than you know whatever we've
done in the past with react what we
wanted to see was this browser window
pop up automatically so what we do have
is that electron starts which is good we
can see it here in the bottom right hand
corner there
that's electron and that's the electron
that we have loaded into our node
modules but there's no window coming up
so we got to figure out why that is
all right and didn't quite get through
everything so I'm gonna make a note of
where I'm stopping and then come back to
it after our next 25-minute coding
session
okay and I'm going to scan quickly to
see what you are saying about our
specific problem here
oh and the link I just pasted it looks
like it's a 404 as well what is up with
both of those links were from medium I
think I don't know what's going on with
that I guess you can try to search then
from react to an electron app ready for
production I guess it's probably the
same problem that we had before
all right
so let me I'm gonna get several
different suggestions it looks like so
let me let me see dependency all right
let's try it looks like rook has
something that we can try very easily to
see if it'll work so let's do this
all right so that's where the shot
because it's just such a simple fix if
it works so let me close that out and
then I want to make sure okay so that
electrons gone from the taskbar that's
good now let's start it up again see
what happens this time so if this works
it'll be awesome otherwise I'll go to
some of the other suggestions that
you'll have in there I always like to
try the easiest thing first you know it
doesn't always work but if it does then
you save a ton of time okay so this is
opening again and we still have nope
looks like nothing let me check my other
screens just to be sure and I don't see
anything yep
not seeing anything okay well that was
worth a shot
let's let me just remove that before I
forget so we have the same thing let me
I'm gonna check so the tutorial came
with a repository github repository so
here's the finished package JSON from
that repository so maybe there's
something in here that didn't get put in
in the tutorial
I've got may be updated afterwards so
let's compare here I'm gonna move I'm
actually a move this on my other screen
so I can compare it with what I have
dependencies
interesting
hmm
okay it doesn't there's a bunch of other
stuff in this package.json so let me
copy and paste that link as well
hopefully it'll this one will work
there's other stuff in here from later
on this tutorial and that's basically
for when we want to package this up when
we're finished with it so we don't need
it now but it looks like of the things
that that we've done so far that we
needed
it's all fine it's the only differences
are our versions so there are some
differences in the versions that we're
using it's possible that that that's the
problem I was a little worried about
this because the tutorial is from June
all right let me check back in the live
chat we'll go to the next suggestion
here
all right let's see all right so a few
of you or say so George and at sheesh
are saying that they think I did not
save the electrons AS VAL I really hope
that that is the issue so let's try it
again now that I've saved it if that was
it I'm gonna be really happy and I'm
going to laugh oh that was it haha yes
I'm so glad that that was it I mean it
it's so silly and I'm sorry that we
wasted so much time check it out here we
go we have a desktop built with reacts
so yeah it's it works and you can see
this is running in the electron window
so it's not like right it says electron
up here right and awesome alright thanks
again George and Ashish you all were
right on target
that was I I can't believe you caught
that and I can't believe I forgot to
save it so sorry I think I already said
I'm sorry but I'll say it again in case
I didn't I am sorry that I forgot to
save this and we'd spent so much time
[Music]
all right okay great
I had to take a drink of my G fuel
energy stuff because I just feel like
yawning all the time and not too good
time to take a little break
so
again if anybody is watching from G fuel
I'd be happy to drink this on every show
if you sent me some for free just
putting that out there
all right great well let me think let me
think when we should do next then I
really thought like oh that's it like
we're not getting anything else done all
right let me check my time okay so it is
2:18 p.m. my time so we are on track I'm
pretty sure I will be able to make it to
my meeting on time okay so we have what
14 more minutes in this Pomodoro cycle
great let's figure out what we're gonna
do then so I'm not gonna touch this file
again since it's working I want to mess
it up let me get rid of some of these
things that I'm not using okay so now
let's check out let me close this we
don't need it and let's check this out
right we have a normal CR @j s right
this is a normal react app right so this
should be yeah I mean I'm assuming that
this should work out just like normal I
also am assuming that there are probably
some things that you can do with
electron to work with some of like the
underlying stuff in the operating system
so if we need to do that which we might
then we'll get to that but for now yes
all right hard [ __ ] you know exactly
what I was going with that right so
harsh it says copy your build files from
the Resource Center to the public folder
and you'll be good to go exact yes
it's just right when I open this up
I started thinking wait a second we use
create react app for the resource center
already so this will definitely work so
let's do that let's first let me find I
think I still have it open I do not have
it open okay let me let me open this up
then I'm just gonna grab the resource
center code from github so on my other
screen that's that's what I'm getting
right now so I we do need to bring in
some stuff from the package.json
probably a lot of stuff
well
hood I need to bring it all right let me
just bring in some of the u.s. stuff cuz
now that I look at this like we have a
formidable package.json file here for
that Resource Center so I'm not gonna
pull everything over right now
okay what's hard saying harsh and says
we bootstrapped oh so harsh it says only
the build files not the source no need
of source really we can just bring over
the billet files all right well let me
get the bill faster
hopefully I built this somewhere let's
go I'm looking for the project folder on
my other screen here the resource center
filled okay and okay
let's copy that and see we're at
uh-huh all right hold on I'm reading
your stuff are you sure don't worry
okay it's a copy the build files to the
public folder all right let's grab these
now make sure what's in here
all right so evidently I can't just copy
and paste right into there let me find
the right folder in my file structure
shouldn't take long here it is there we
go
yes sir please sir please
oh there see what's gonna happen I
suppose and run app in production
all right so what do I do to earn this
okay so as it says in the build folder
okay so not in the public folder in the
build folder all right
No
well it's just happened
I can't dang it alright so
I was fine what did we have for index
dang it
okay
I just changed the dev stuff from line
number 13
we talk about line number 13 and our
package.json or in another folder or
another file I mean in electron died yes
okay 113 okay so this is set for the
build file okay all right let me grab
that build folder and bring it in the
whole folder this time
okay so you should have a build folder
now why did it show up I see like shondo
mm-hm
that's weird all right so hard saying
remove local oh okay okay I'll just do
this
that'll work right because it'll flip
around that ternary all right so let's
start this again
see what happens
all right so I'm getting something so it
now says resource center did it say
resource center before I don't even
remember I don't think it did it did
open so here's where it opened that it
didn't really do anything let's check
out our it actually shouldn't be running
should it yeah it should not well I mean
should we have it okay it does it's yarn
start so that that does make sense
all right then
all right how do I open dev tools in
here there's got to be a
okay
I thought I saw something about dev
tools late I think it was later on in
the anything so actually there's a lot
more to this tutorial so maybe maybe I
should have gone through the whole thing
first ctrl shift I
all right so it's not working for me so
let's do
okay
all right so let's see the top bar
yes awesome great job thanks I should so
the top bar did have an option to open
dev tools so where is my dark theme that
come on what is it gonna work NoHo I
can't do the dark theme on here I don't
know we might just have to quit this
project can't can't work with all this
white hum alright so let's see what's
going on
okay all right this makes sense so since
we didn't actually build things we just
transferred this over these files
statics you suspend no wait a second
they should still be there I still can't
see it in there
all right let me find it build static it
says now they're there I can see them in
the file structure
hmm
all right so why
maybe I need I should say change it to
file protocol in the files I am not sure
hard [ __ ] I'm not sure what your what
you're asking me to do so sorry about
that
if you explain it to me a little more
please
haha michael says after everything else
this morning a lack of a dark theme and
dev tools might make you click is a sack
of it I will really quit over the lack
of a dark theme
okay I get it all right this will be me
check my time this would be the last
thing I do
if it works awesome if not we'll just
continue this a different day so harsh
is saying change it from HTTP to file
because this thinks it's a plain URL and
this thing so you can clean you up okay
so let's see okay yeah so it is saying
file here now where
all right so where my I'm gonna look for
this ad why can i still not see this
folder wanna like refresh
oh well I'll just open em anyway
there is a refresh icon in here oh there
it is
yes awesome thank you again
Harshit in case you didn't catch it
earlier I'm gonna use Visual Studio code
now which is not my normal editor so if
I make mistakes in here I blame it on
that alright let's check it out and see
we should be trying to get the files
somewhere in here right there we go so
if we change this to file right and what
it was the same file
so
static CSS man so
excuse me
and what else we looking for main
instead
there we go
do we need these slashes probably not
right do we see if this will work three
slashes
all right we'll try that so Cameron
Cameron saying three slashes we'll give
it a shot and whoa looks like a
background kind of all right just close
this for now see what happens
it's so still same thing let's see what
the air is this time where did we find
that before there we go
hey the dark theme it came back okay so
the project is saved now
okay Jambi says the triple slash is
normal for the file protocol and header
in Chrome when the path is localhost
remove the slash how many of the slashes
Jordan says I hate Jordan how's it going
alright let's try to remove one slash
now
okay Harsha say we move all remove all
the slashes all right
and I remove everything all right let's
try that then
as she says and drop now show this
resource center that's cool tell me all
right leave it shut
all right cool check it out
oh nice look at that eye it's working
all right so cool
nice
well
very cool so I mean we have some some
stuff right
that's not exactly working correctly but
a lot of the content is there if some
weird stuff there's some weirdness going
on with the hover so it's not perfect
but I mean that's a lot like that's that
saved a lot of time very cool all right
okay cool so that's all I'm gonna do
today as far as code for the rest of the
time that I have which is maybe like 10
minutes I'm gonna try to get through as
much of the live chat as I can and I try
to answer all your questions so if you
have any questions please put them in
the chat now if we get a lot of
questions I may not be able to get to
all of them but I will try my best and
if you don't care to stay for the
question-and-answer session thank you so
much for watching and please join me
back here again usually around 2 p.m.
Eastern Time as when I stream and of
course you can always check out the
recordings they're always available here
on the free code camp YouTube channel
all right where'd I leave off
okay cool I'm gonna switch back over to
this and I'll go back to the the view of
my desktop if we get a question that
pertains to that so a lot of the stuff
in the chat now you all trying to help
me out with these mistakes I was making
so I'm gonna be skipping quite a bit
okay hards asked if i checked out native
base i've not checked it out electronic
maybe I have to check that out it says
it uses next which is cool because I'm
already familiar with next so thanks
everyone for for you know this all the
suggestions we were trying to figure out
what was going on I see a lot of you has
some good suggestions there
Nicholas says thanks for doing this I
don't have time to fall along with you
but I want to come back and work through
the recording awesome yeah and if you
can't be here in the live chat that's
cool if you have any questions just send
them to me on Twitter or put them in the
comments to the videos and I'll try to
get you an answer as soon as I can
Blake says I saw Murder on the Orient
Express last night it was awesome
I'm glad you liked it I have not seen it
but now maybe I'll check it out
now let's see horseshit had an idea to
try this on a clone of the Resource
Center actually that would have been a
much better idea would have resulted in
the same thing right but instead of
having a copy and paste off I would have
yeah that would have been cool too
at some at some point Roland said time
to update your resume I'm not I don't
know what that was in reference to so if
you're still watching let me know I'm
not sure what I was talking about at
that point in the live chat or maybe
Ron's not even addressing that to me I'm
not sure let me know please
Dmitri said how to be so cool coder like
he I don't know about being cool but
Dmitri if you're still here watching us
I would try if you want to start out
being a coder I don't know how much you
know already but if you're just
beginning check out free cocaine org
sign up try out some of the exercises
they're pretty they're pretty easy at
first and then get harder but that might
give you an idea of maybe if you kind of
like that kind of like front-end
programming stuff there's a lot of other
things to do but check that out I guess
there's a ton of other resources so if
you're interested let me know send me
something on Twitter or you know here in
the live chat or something and I'd be
happy to talk to you to figure out what
you're interested in and point you in
the right direction maybe
see Sanjay's had hide just joining the
stream what has been happening since the
start of the stream it looks like her
she gave gave an answer there
that was good basically says we
bootstrapped an electron react project
yep that's pretty much it we just did
the basic setup create react app and we
added an electron and then that gave us
we copied over some files from another
project and that gave us kind of a basic
basic app there's still some things that
aren't working right and we haven't even
tested out the forms at all so there's
still some work to be done but we
definitely saved a lot of time with
actually building things out in
designing
let's see I've got some writing and
maybe is that Cyrillic characters so let
me get out my trusty Google Translate
here and see what that is
so it looks like if Ilya says glory to
Ukraine all right so I guess it is from
Ukraine cool thanks for watching
how cool michael said i'm off to try the
Pomodoro clock on free code camp awesome
I probably not still listening since you
said that ten minutes ago
but good luck with that and once you
finish it I'd love to see it if you have
it publicly available or I get over
something so let me know if you're cool
with me looking at it
Nino's says how long have you been
coding five years but the first like
year I wasn't I was working on websites
but it was mostly like CSS stuff really
basic I don't I don't know some I don't
know if you call CSS work and HTML stuff
coding or not so depending you know but
definitely for the last like solid like
three years of JavaScript and I've been
a full-time front-end developer for a
little over two years now
Harshit says can you show us the react
native stuff is it working native base
and splash screen stuff yeah it's
working it is working let me I turned
off the server let me let me turn it
back on so I'm gonna turn off this for
now because they're both trying to run
on for 3,000 all right
[Music]
all right it's gonna run I'll try to run
it in the emulator but last time I tried
to do that it's um oh shoot am i
starting the wrong thing I think I am I
am hold on I have it over here there we
go
anyway last time I tried to start the
iOS emulator it didn't work so I'll give
it a shot again if not I'm just gonna
have to put my phone up to the camera
which I know is not ideal actually I
could use I might have a better option
we'll see let's see what happens
hi oh s emulator come on work this son
hmm okay did not work this time maybe I
have to update some stuff let's go with
because of a problem that's very
descriptive it's a simulator cannot be
open because of a problem all right you
know what we'll probably let's save this
for another stream because I could
probably try to open it while I'm
answering other questions but I have a
meeting in 6 minutes right now so let me
okay I'll try to get it on here all
right so let's hear you check this out
here if it is gonna work you'll you'll
see it work I'll keep reading let's see
you know it says what other technologies
do you know no that's something went
wrong no I try it again it was it
seriously just worked earlier today
that's okay I know so in addition to
HTML CSS and JavaScript alright I'll
just show you all tomorrow I would love
to show you right now I just don't have
time to figure out why this isn't
working so in addition to HTML
Javascript CSS I know a little bit of
PHP a tiny tiny bit of c-sharp I once
made a calculator in C++ but I don't
remember pretty much any of it now
that's about it I've done like super
basic things in Java and in Python so I
think that's that's it like coding was
nina says do you have a website or
portfolio I do have a website that
that's old and hasn't been updated in a
really long time it's just Jessie Weigel
comm if you want to see it don't laugh
when you see it actually you can laugh
if you want to it's like I said it's
been a really long time since I worked
on that site a better thing is to check
out my github page which is linked in
the description check that out that has
my recent projects in it
Dimitri says why are you so relaxed I
don't know this is just my normal I'm
not really sure why why you're asking if
I'm so relaxed
I think I'm generally a pretty relaxed
person
see
I should asked if I had Xcode installed
I do have Xcode installed but it's
possible that it needs updated Rowan
said use visor to mirror the screen I do
that visor I just didn't think I'd have
time to get it started all right okay
three minutes to my meeting so I really
do have to go now thank you everyone for
watching and for participating a live
chat you all helped so much when I was
messing things up but it's really cool
first time ever for me and for the
stream we got a an electron app started
and it's actually running right now on
my iMac and well it was running I just
shut it off but it was ready and we had
styles there were buttons and links and
they worked so really cool I'm excited
about that we got further along than I
thought we would which is great and
tomorrow I'm not sure what we'll be
working on tomorrow cuz we have a lot of
projects going on right now but I'll
figure it out when I get in tomorrow
morning and I'll see everyone tomorrow
until then have a great day